is there an antagonist or a dark side to
romantic comedies and antagonist or a
dark side I think in romantic comedies
the antagonist is either within or
usually just without but not big okay we
take three levels of opposition there's
internal and then there's opposition
from those around you family society
culture and then on a bigger level of
stories there's the opposition from the
big outside you know bureaucracies
aliens you know tsunamis but in a
romantic comedy you want antagonists and
opposition just at those two levels the
close two levels it's a this is a small
story we're not taking on the world
we're not trying to overthrow kingdoms
so your opposition can be an another
person or a bunch of people family
society culture sometimes religion but
usually not because it can be problems
in them try to have a comedy to get into
you know those deeper philosophical
questions but so often the main
antagonist is within one's own self take
for instance my best friend's wedding
Julia Roberts main antagonist was
herself and what she thought she should
have and how she thought it should be
and that was enough opposition to carry
that whole film because there was no one
else against her now the situation was
against her because the guy was engaged
and he was getting married but nobody
was coming against her in particular she
was doing it all to herself in My Big
Fat Greek Wedding you had both those
levels the insecurity and then the
family saying well no you got to marry a
nice Greek boy and be Greek like you're
a great person be a Greek person so two
levels four antagonists and opposition
you know
to comedy and he said earlier that
before starting this book you weren't a
huge fan of romantic comedies but what
films did you actually enjoy of that
genre well I did have my favorites
already
and certainly Love Actually is my
favorite because it's got so many
different love stories in it of so many
different types and it's so well crafted
every writer should watch and
deconstruct Love Actually to see how you
can create and sustain character arcs
many of them over the course of a film
and have what seven eight ten storylines
going on and they all work together and
they're all interconnected and it's it's
brilliant it's brilliant writing and
filmmaking and the stories and the
characters are so endearing so loved
actually I do like down with love and
Mamma Mia because it's so much fun to
sing to seriously can you watch Mamma
Mia and not sing no you can't
you